[Music]
this episode of shots of Oz brought to
you by the Toyota Prius let's lead the
way
people talk a lot these days about our
increasingly fragmented lives living our
lives online and somehow it's not real
it's not accurate we're not really
exchanging intimacy's on facebook and
twitter is what people argue but there's
a term out there that i found much more
interesting that actually says look our
exchanges may not be the same as in the
mead space but there's still real
exchanges and I think the term used was
ambient intimacy that you know seeing
bits and pieces of your friends and
families digital lives
you know seeing snippets of a photograph
seeing an announcement of a birthday you
know seeing with stuff that they're
posting does give you a sort of
perspective a sort of taste of where
they're at you are getting an accurate
picture an accurate snapshot and
accurate exchange of where this person
is at in their lives there's nothing
inauthentic about this interpersonal
exchange that's occurring all the time
in other words it's just another space
for communication it's not better or
worse except for the fact that it does
collapse geography it gets rid of the
limitations of time space and distance
and allows us to expand the parameters
of what we can sample right the Internet
is an infinite campus bar and so maybe
we're not having the full meal of just
one thing anymore but we're certainly
expanding our horizons and expanding our
possibility space and expanding the
divine spaces you know where we can
travel to you know this indictment of
technology is indictment of
transformation of social media I think a
lot of times customer place of fear
rather than two places actually
appreciating transformation and
evolution in how we communicate
[Music]